We glossed over this very quickly in the beginning of this,
but there was a dispute about cholesterol and a dispute about saturated fat
NA Sears, you were saying that saturated fat,
that there's recommendations to reduce saturated fat and reduce cholesterol.
A real quick overview, and I'm going to talk fast,
so it was plenty of time.
It was felt so until the forties it was not common to have a heart attack.
Heart attacks were described in 1916 not to say they didn't happen,
but the first medical article that used the word myocardial infarction 1916 1940
there were not many heart attacks seen in a modern American city.
After world war II, we, our economy went up in the city of Mina,
Minneapolis executives started suffering heart attacks.
It was also Franklin Delano Roosevelt died of high blood pressure.
A few years later, Eisenhower had a massive heart attack.
That's when our government,
national institutes of health started funneling major money into studies like
the Framingham study or from Newton Framingham's a city outside of Boston,
and they basically invaded this town in 1958 till today.
So we're spending money. We're going to figure this crap out.
The idea had come up. Heart disease wasn't just aging.
Heart disease could be explained by what's called risk factors.
Smoking might not,
you can smoke and live to a hundred but it's going to increase your risk and
then they got into blood pressure and cholesterol and a family history.
They identified what we call risk factors. So until that point,
diet was not considered a factor in the development.
The number one killer of men and women I want to point out,
and Chris puts this on his website, I do too during this interview,
every 39 seconds in American dies of heart disease,
every 39 second the most frequent cause of death.
So there will be about 200 people perhaps that will die during this podcast and
the number one killer and 80% of it's preventable.
Chris is going to prevent some,
I'm going to prevent some cause the biggest enemy out there, smoking and crap,
diet, calorie rich and processed foods, crap, sad diet, standard American diet.
It became apparent in the early 1950s diet might play a role in a notorious
scientist and many others. His name, dr ancil keys, PhD,
PhD at two of them suggested dietary fat might be a factor.
It was a hypothesis. It's as early stage epidemiology doesn't prove anything.
He went out and did studies.
Other people went out and did studies and the idea transitioned actually he was
criticized for saying dietary fat, the disease, the,
the conversation transition.
There's some good fats like Omega three fatty acids are essential.
You have to have them.
And then maybe polyunsaturated fats from plants are more helpful.
But the focus went on saturated fat in food. We just make a chicken,
red meat pizza. Those are the highest sources. And, um,
subsequently an data accumulated that guidelines started to suggest we've got
this huge problem with heart disease. We should limit saturated fat in the diet.
It was never limit off that 35% of calories that's not in anybody's word,
a low fat diet. Um,
and that has now promulgated in 20 international statements.
There is no opposite whether it's a world health organization,
the American heart association, American college of cardiology,
whether it's the Institute of Institute of medicine says eat as little saturated
fat as possible. They couldn't be more clear and these are high brow.
These are not associated with vegan movements or paleo movements or whatever.
These are medical authorities.
If there was half and half you'd say controversy 21 to 21 say the same thing.
They might pick a different cutoff point,
but we will enhance the health and cut down the number one killer,
whether it's in Asia, whether it's Europe, whether it's Australia,
whether it's in the United States.
There's unanimity and why did they come to the
basic science? Because there is basic science and let me tell you yet,
when you eat foods rich in saturated fat, which is called meat, cheese,
eggs and such receptors on your liver for cholesterol, I've got cholesterol,
my blood, I'd like to get some of it out into the liver to be metabolized.
I need a receptor. You eat saturated fats, receptors go down.
Cholesterol has no place to go.
Cholesterol stays in the blood bumps into your artery wall.
I'm putting a stent in Yardi. That's the basic biochemistry.
Then they had epidemiology studies. Flawed. Perfect. It doesn't matter.
There was cells, man. Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, Chris, Chris. Thank you very much.
Then they did controlled trials.
Three everybody just go read Clark 1997 395 it's called metabolic studies.
Change the diet. See what happens. You add, say trait of fat.
Cholesterol skyrockets on average, not in a single person.
If I give you a steak, Chris's steak and me a steak,
our cluster would rise differently. It would rise. It would rise differently.
It's our microbiome. It's our genetics. It would rise.
So if that's a problem in the studies when you average everything together.
So they had that and then finally,
finally they looked at populations that live over a hundred these are called the
pillars of longevity. They don't eat foods rich and saturated fat.
They have a little, they don't have a lot.
They eat a lot of olive oil in Italy and Greece.
They eat almost no dietary fat in Okinawa, Japan, and they live.
They have the greatest longevity in the world in 1970 they eat almost no dietary
fat. About six, 7%. Okay to gather. No,
it's actually,
that is the basis for a major push to say cut back on animal products.
Cause that's largely with the exception of coconut and Palm, uh,
know where saturated fat comes from.
So the to negate that is to throw out every major health agency in the world
that I don't believe Chris Kresser can do that. No disrespect.
I don't think Chris [inaudible]
throw out a hundred years of clusteral risks. Let's back up a little bit here.
Yeah. So, um, first of all,
every food that we consume has all of the fats in it, polyunsaturated,
monounsaturated and saturated fat. And in fact,
two tablespoons of olive oil has more saturated fat than a seven ounce pork
chop. That's a little known fact. Um, the, the oily fish macro, you know,
which all of these health agencies that Joel is talking about advises us to eat,
has twice the total fat and one and a half times the saturated fat that we're of
the meat that we're told to avoid. Um, does it make sense that nature, you know,
would include the, that you can eat, uh, uh, you know,
macro and the polyunsaturated fats in it are good for you,
but the saturated fat in it is bad for you. That's kind of nonsensical.
But you know, th let's talk a little bit more about the research. So,
um,
there never really was good evidence to suggest that dietary cholesterol and
saturated fat are connected to heart disease. And, uh, Zoe [inaudible] who's,
uh, has a PhD in nutritional researcher, she wrote her thesis,
her PhD thesis on the evidence back in the 70s that led to the restrictions on,
uh, saturated fat and cholesterol. And then she also reviewed the evidence.
You're all the way up until 2016. And, and if, uh, I have the,
uh, this information on my website, if you go kresser.com/rogan,
you can find it. And what you'll find is there never was really good, uh,
evidence to support the limitations on dye, on saturated fat and cholesterol.
And people have started to look at this more recently. And, uh,
for example,
you have a meta analysis of observational studies including about 350,000
participants recently that found no relationship between saturated fat intake
and cardiovascular disease.
You have an exhaustive review of studies,
something like 25 randomized controlled trials,
gold standard of clinical evidence and almost 40 observational studies involving
650,000 participants. And I'll read you a quote from the conclusion.
Current evidence does not clearly support cardiovascular guidelines that
encourage high consumption of polyunsaturated fatty acids and low consumption of
saturated fatty acids. Now look,
one of my favorite quotes is the F the philosopher, Anatoly France.
Even if 50 million people say a foolish thing, it's still a foolish thing.
And the other thing to consider is that the history of science is really the
history of most scientists being wrong about most things most of the time.
And, uh, you know, in science we have to continually challenge our,
our hypotheses and try to falsify them.
And that's how the scientific process moves forward.
And that's why in 2010 the U S, uh,
federal government removed restrictions on total fat, whereas before,
there was a restriction on total fat because they,
they acknowledged that the research was showing that not all fat is the same and
that, you know,
we don't need to be restricting fat from avocados and things like that.
And then in 2015, they removed the restriction on dietary cholesterol.
Now they did that fairly quietly because how do you think it looks when people
have been told to, you know, limit their fat and limit their cholesterol.
And then the, the eight federal agency goes back on that,
that recommendation after so many years of telling people to do that,
people lose faith in the agencies that are, that are issuing these guidelines.
You know, and don't take it from me. You know, I'm, I'm,
I'm not expecting anyone to believe me. And that's why I've put all of the,
the studies and the research supporting this at kresser.com/rogan.
But how about Johnny nidus,
who's one of the most renowned epidemiologists in the world?
He's a professor of medicine at Stanford and he has wrote some written,
some scathing critiques of nutritional research recently that had been published
in JAMA and British medical journal. So here's a quote from one of them.
Some nutrition scientists and much of the public often consider epidemiological
associations of nutritional factors to represent causal effects that can inform
public health policy and guidelines. However,
the emerging picture of nutritional epidemiology is difficult to reconcile with
good scientific principles.
The field needs radical reform and he goes on to point out that meta analyses of
observational studies have found that almost all foods are associated with a
higher risk of death if you crunch the data in certain ways. So,
uh, it's not enough to say that, that, you know,
governments are recommending this or that we have to look at the science and
what the science is saying. And as I said,
two recent meta analysis covering over a million people are not showing a
relationship between saturated fat and heart disease and they're not showing any
benefit from replacing saturated fat with polyunsaturated fats.
So these organizations, Joel, that you were describing,
why do you think that they recommend, based on what Chris has just said,
why do you think that they recommend reducing your saturated fat,
reducing your cholesterol. Okay. Um, and thank you and you know,
the importance here, which we are, you know, technical in the weeds,
but I want to bring it back, this discussion is do you have a stroke,
heart attack out of this function, lose a leg or do you not?
Because at least one factor in development of these horrible medical problems
that are 80% preventable,
at least one of it is your nutrition and the continuity nutrition.
I mean there's no doubt it's a single most important factor.
It's never been the only fact. Okay.
But [inaudible] organizations are saying this,
he's saying the studies don't support that. Well, uh,
I just agree that the science, and I want to be very specific.
Let's talk about cholesterol. Let's talk about sensory fat.
So stay with saturated fat cause there is differences there. They're both, uh,
you know, contents of food, fatty contents of food,
but they're chemically different. And the volume weight is very, very different.
Um, cholesterol only comes from animals, saturated fat as animals and plants,
uh, depending on the food source. So when this rise in heart attacks developed,
research began 1948 and 1950, 1958.
There were observations made that carefully done dietary logs suggested these
were hypotheses.
There might be a connection between what you eat and heart attacks.
And then it's centered on, um, you know, is it foods high in protein,
foods high in sugar, foods, high in fatty sources.
Ultimately they got sophisticated food, Italian plant fat sources,
foods high in animal fat sources. So by the late 1950s,
there was a very strong consensus already that foods high in animal products
with saturated fat. They go together. We're talking meat,
egg and cheese may be a role. Why, let me give you a great example. In 1959,
you grew up in Japan. You have a cholesterol of 120.
You almost never see a heart attack.
You move to Hawaii because there's migration. Your cholesterol rises to 180.
Welcome to America. Your heart attack, risk triples.
You move to this great city, Los Angeles,
which was published in 1959 your cluster is now to 10 you have 10 times the
heart attack risk that you had when you lived in Japan.
Genetics don't change that quick. This was within one generation.
They're called Nisei people that leave Japan to move to California, the Nisei,
and there's the Nisei Hahn study that tracked these people. Now is it the air?
Is it that they adopted other bad habits? Shirt could be,
but within a very short time they had 10 times the risk of heart attack.
So public research and dollars.
This stuff matters correlated with animal fats and protein.
Why isn't it correlated with sugar and refined carbohydrates?
So carefully done studies say,
and I think we all agree more so now because we're overweight and now we're more
insulin resistant and added sugars in the diet are more important in 2018 than
they were. I'm in the country was thin in 1960 they weren't good then.
They aren't good now, but when you parse it out, multivariate analysis,
there's a stronger relationship between the number one food and studies like
this is usually butter more than red meat. It's actually butter.
That's just an R value. It's called the statistic.
I don't want to go so deep into statistics. It is somewhere there is sugar.
I'll give you a classic study.
If you could hold sugar the same and increase dietary saturated fat,
heart disease, rockets, if you could hold saturated fat,
the same increased sugar and these manipulations of coronary heart disease
doesn't increase. Let's point something out.
I've been inside a hearts 15,000 times.
I've never scooped sugar out of a blocked artery.
I scooped cholesterol out of blocked arteries.
20% of every blockage in a heart is cholesterol.
It's a fact that was discovered in 1910 it's never varied.
Then we've fed animal. Let's pause for a second. Chris,
you have something to say about that,
so that doesn't mean that the cholesterol is there because people were eating
it. Joel, you know that could be though.
Let me, let's say, let's look at the, what the research says again here.
So they've done controlled feeding studies where they fed people two to four
eggs a day,
and those show that in 75% of cases that has zero impact on blood cholesterol
levels for the other 25% of people,
they're termed hyper responders and in that group,
dietary cholesterol or does modestly increase LDL cholesterol,
but it also increases HDL cholesterol and it does not increase the risk of heart
disease.
This is why the guidelines were changed on dietary cholesterol is there is no
evidence that the consuming dietary cholesterol increases the risk of blood
cholesterol. Most people, and even when it does,
there's no evidence that it increases the risk of a heart attack,
which is again, why the dietary guidelines change for saturated fat.
Again, most of the studies showed harm were short term studies.
These longer term studies have shown that on average eating saturated fat does
not increase the saturated fat levels in the blood and have all of the longterm
studies that looked at this.
Only one showed any association between saturated fat intake and uh,
cholesterol levels in the blood. Then we have a meta analysis,
lots of meta-analyses actually,
but one of the best known meta-analyses was of 17 randomized controlled trials
of low carb diets that were high in saturated fats and published in the journal
of obesity reviews and they found that low carb diets neither increased nor
decreased LDL cholesterol.
But what they did find was that low carb diets are associated with decrease in
body weight improvements in several cardiovascular risks,
risk factors including triglycerides, fasting glucose, blood pressure,
body mass index, abdominal circumference, plasma insulin,
C reactive protein as well as an increase in HDL cholesterol.
Now there have now been 10 meta analyses of randomized controlled trials looking
at low carb diets for weight loss.
All 10 showed that uh,
the low carb diet either outperformed in most cases or was,
was on the S at the same level as low fat diets.
There have been several meta-analyses now you can see them all at
kresser.co/rogan that have looked at um,
low carb diets for diabetes and even cardiovascular risk markers.
And all of these meta analyses have found that low carb diets are superior for
glycaemic control, for reducing insulin, for reducing triglycerides,
and have beneficial effects across the board without increasing cardiovascular
risk markers. So we're now we're talking about randomized controlled trials,
which is the best form of evidence that we have and we're not seeing any harm
from increase, you know, increased consumption of saturated fat.
So is the problem that you're citing epidemiologist studies from the 1940s and
the 1950s I would definitely go.
I think we need to PR to prefer randomized controlled trials over that kind of
evidence for sure.
Why do you continue to go back to these studies from the 1940 and 1950s
beginning? Well the beginning,
but Chris just took 14 topics and put them into one for meta analysis or as
controls to low carb, low fat.
I mean they're all different topics and I dunno how you put that all together.
You need clarity and laser focus. So we were talking saturated fat.
I mean, so hypothesis is generated saturated fat in the diet. Butter,
eggs and cheese may be bad for heart disease,
something killing Americans left to right in 1940 1950s.
Let's go into countries with widely different diets.
Let's see what they're eating.
Let's actually take their friggin diet back to Minneapolis. Let's analyze it.
So it's not guessing, not food frequency questionnaires.
We're taking their meals back, the United States analyze them, but boom,
there's a relationship between dietary saturated fat and your risk.
50 year followup. There's no short term followup.
The study I'm referring to has 50 or felt 1958 to now and um,
that strongly suggested that dietary saturated fat and heart disease,
that doesn't, that's not what's called the ultimate randomized clinical study,
but it's one high quality second study done in China at the same time with,
you know, years of followup. So these are right up to date.
There's publications right now from studies starting at then,
but the publications are now, but then you get the best kind of study. Okay.
I'm still on saturated fat. I'm not talking any other topic.
You put people in a metabolic ward at the national Institute of health,
395 of these studies published in 1979 you change their diet.
This is the ultimate careful experiment.
It might be for four weeks or six weeks you up their saturated fat,
their cholesterol rises, your sugars can be, we're all different.
That change in cholesterol is consistent.
You're going to go up 20% 20% 20% we start at different points.
You have to track the change in cholesterol. Chris referred to, actually,
can I go off on a tangent? It's really interesting.
This will fascinate your listeners, but it's right on the topic.
2008 this is published data. I don't bullshit on this.
2008 Mexico city, the national,
they international dairy council meet and they publish their notes,
which is why we know this and they said we are losing the battle.
People are eating less dairy around the world and we are losing sales.
What we can do is influence researchers, influence expeditions,
insistent speaker. Well, it's every,
every dairy council in the world just happens to meet in Mexico city that year.
Then they go meet in Portugal. Then they go meet in New York, whatever,
2008 we're going to put dollars into changing research and influencing people.
Doesn't mean it's all bad.
They publish those notes that are global initiative for the next year.
They looked for sympathetic researchers that would change public opinion and
that was right before the milk mustache campaign. They find a guy,
I actually respect now, but I'm going to beat him up a little. Dr Ronald Krauss,
MD in Berkeley, California, right by him runs it a lipid center.
He's had beef funding for 10 years. He's had dairy funding.
All of a sudden he's speaking to dairy industries all over.
In 2010 two years later he publishes, we call it a meta analysis.
That's not new research,
that's statistical playing with previous studies that can be fair,
can be unfair, whatever, whatever it is.
Their conclusion is they could not find and verify that saturated fat in the
diet, butter, eggs, and cheese raises the risk of heart disease.
They never said eat butter, eggs and cheese. They just couldn't verify it.
What's amazing, it's an American journal of clinical nutrition.
That same journal is a, is a editorial that destroys the study.
This is 15 reasons. This is horrible.
Epidemiology by guy named Jeremiah Stamler.
I've never seen a medical journal destroy a piece that they accepted for
publication. Okay? So everything's like stirred up.
And 2014, a guy named Chowdry publishes a similar analysis.
That is the reason that time magazine put on the cover.
Butter is back because it not new research. It's a meta analysis.
It's all following this Mexico city, uh,
effort to fund dairy positive publications.
A study so bad that both the journal required them to adjust and republish the
data cause of mistakes. The Harvard school of public health said,
take this thing away. Statistically, this is nonsense. Since those two times,
and that's just the bottom line, we have had confusion in the public.
We've got experts like Chris experts like me, experts like dr Mark Hyman,
experts like Dr. Walter Willett on and on.
There is a quote from the tobacco industry that our product is confusion.
They didn't care about, you know, winning the battle when the public's confused,
we're just going to keep on doing habits they have.
And that is got to stop because now we're in the weeds with conspiracy theories
to saturated fat.
So that's when the pendulum of 1950 1960 1997,
395 of the best done studies in the world. Say you eat more saturated fat,
your cholesterol goes up, more saturated fat, corn, heart disease goes up.
It was Clarissa, it'll clear. And the guidelines said,
the guidelines still say it.
The guidelines still say limits the same science from the 1950s and the 1940s is
applicable today. If it's in retrospect valid. Hey,
let's point out one minute. Yeah, absolutely. Do you think it is? Absolutely.
We're
going back to observational studies done 50 60 years ago that suffer from all of
the problems that I mentioned and to begin with.
And several more that we didn't have time to go into. Um,
we have randomized controlled trials now and you know,
observational studies were never meant to prove a hypothesis.
They're meant to generate a hypothesis.
And it's true that in some cases it's not possible to do a randomized controlled
trial. Like with cigarette smoking, you'd have to have,
the trial lasts for so long and you'd have to isolate people and award so they
weren't exposed to air pollution and other factors that can affect the result.
You can't do that. But in that case the risk was a thousand to 3000% higher.
So their criteria called the Bradford Hill criteria,
which you can use and apply to observational studies to assess the chance that
there's a causal relationship. And in the case of smoking,
which actually was when the Bradford Bradford Hill criteria were created,
that really that meets many of those criteria.
In the case of nutrition research,
very seldom did they meet more than a couple of the Bradford Hill criteria.
Now, observational research, in order to be valuable, it needs to be confirmed.
You know, the results need to be replicated in a randomized controlled trial.
That's how science is supposed to work.
But there was one analysis that found that zero of 52 claims that were made in
observational nutrition studies were replicated when they were tested later and
in fact five were replicated in the opposite direction. In other words, they,
when they did an experiment, they found the opposite result,
what the observational suggested.
So a good examples of this are observational studies originally suggested that
beta carotene, an antioxidant,
that people with the highest intake of beta care team had something like a 30%
reduced risk of death, which is not really plausible anyways.
But then when they started doing trials where they were giving people beta
carotene supplements, not only did it not improve their lifespan,
they got more cancer, it increased the risk of cancer.
So this is why it's so important not to rely just on observational data and to
do these experiments. Now going back to saturated fat. As I said,
we've got a 2013 meta analysis of 20 randomized controlled trials that found
that low carb,
high protein diets lead to greater improvements in glycaemic control compared to
low fat American heart association, American diabetic association diets.
We've got a 2014 meta analysis of 10 randomized controlled trials that showed
that low carb diets are more effective than high carb diets for patients with
type two diabetes.
And we've got another meta analysis of 25 randomized controlled trials just
published in 2018 that found the same thing. So you know,
science marches on, we learn more, we change,
and now we've got randomized controlled trials that are replacing some of the
observational evidence from the fifties and sixties and seventies which,
which by the way, and dr hark homes paper,
you'll see that that evidence was never strong to begin with.
And this is what we should be looking at.